[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we have considered
this problem
uh where both lateral and axial load was
present
to induce bending as well as stretching
and we had
addressed uh or we had achieved the goal
of arriving at the governing
differential equations
and the boundary conditions using the
principle
of stationary potential energy now we
are going to do the exact same thing
but this time using the principle of
virtual work all right so
uh the the procedure will be exactly the
same
as uh as in the video uh
in the as in the earlier video involving
the
the use of the principle of virtual work
where we had addressed the problem
uh where only lateral load was present
and axial load was absent
but this time even the exit load is
present uh i mean the basic procedure is
the same
so let's see what happens so i'll skip a
couple of steps
uh like this it is exactly the same as
before
uh where i had arrived
at this particular form of uh
of the principle of virtual work uh from
our energy methods chapter
let me just write that down integration
sigma i j
delta epsilon i j
this integration being over the entire
volume
and this is equal to e
i the traction vector multiplied with
the
first variation of the displacement
vector and this integration being
carried out over the entire surface
of of the volume under concern
now how do we apply this thing over here
so we have already applied this up on
the problem where only the lateral load
was present all that you have to do
is to incorporate the effect of this c
the axial load but of course as a result
of this axial load as we've seen in the
previous video
where we had used the principle of
stationary potential energy this axial
load induces
an an axial stretching
that is represented by the variable us
so
as we had proceeded earlier uh in the
in the in the use of the principle of
virtual work we will start out
with our simplifying assumptions based
on the kinematical
hypothesis
so these are some some basic starting
out
assumptions regarding the nature of the
deformations
uh what we say here uh so we had spent
a considerable amount of time discussing
why this
u can be represented in this term
of minus z dw
the x which represented the
the the deflection of a material point
which was not lying
on the center line of this beam okay
so uh there what we had
said was that for points which would be
lying on the center line or for any
other point
uh there would be no deflection uh or
let me let me correct myself what we had
mentioned there
was that uh when this
p load was absent so so back when we
were considering
the problem involving only the lateral
load we had said that there
would be no displacement of the
particles which are lying
along the center line of this beam along
the x direction
however in the presence of this lat of
this axial load which is present now
there will be definitely the is some
displacement
of of those points and we represent that
by this variable us that is the
stretching variable
with regards to v it still remains a
zero so there is no deformation or
displacement
uh in the direction out of the plane of
the screen
uh which is this y so let me write that
down
so out of the plane of the screen here
that is my y direction that is my y
and down below that is
my z okay the w
again will be a pure function of
x which so we start out with this uh
simplifying assumptions
regarding the nature of the of the
geometry
and as a result of this kinematical
hypothesis
we can immediately write down the
various components
of the strings using the strain
displacement relations
so please note that this epsilon x x is
equal to
del u del x i'd made a slight mistake as
you had just seen that
i've undone that mistake i'd written
this as us that would be completely
wrong
okay so this needs to be over the entire
variable
u so this is uh
is going to give us minus z
d squared w dx
squared uh plus
e u s e x so let me
copy this thing out here cut it out from
here and place it
a more convenient location
okay
so next we have for epsilon yy
del v del y that is 0
epsilon z that is del w
del z that is also equal to 0 because w
is a pure function
of x and here v is this is 0 so that's
y epsilon y y is 0. next for epsilon x y
i have half del u del y
plus del v del x
and you know that this u of
this expression u it is not a function
of
y so this first term is 0 and the second
term is 0 because v
itself is zero next
epsilon y z this is equal to half
del v del z plus
del w del y and this is again 0
because v itself is 0 and w is a pure
function of x
and finally for epsilon z x we have half
del w del x plus
del u del z
and that is going to give us uh
of t w d x because w is a pure function
of x
and this del u del z that gives us
minus dw dx please note
that this us again is just a pure
function
of x okay so this is also zero so the
only non-zero component of
uh the strain that is present is this
epsilon
xa okay uh
next what we are going to say is that
for our material behavior we are going
to use
sigma xx is equal to exxx
okay so let me go to the next slide
this we have used earlier and we
continue to use this
up now if we
if we go back to that expression which
we had written in the previous
slide or page of this
sigma i j del i j del epsilon i j
d v equal to
t i
delta u y d s so
what this is going to give me is
sigma x x delta
epsilon x x dv
integrate over the entire volume and for
here
what i am going to obtain is the
contribution
uh from the forces or the loads
which are externally applied and we i'm
going to write this
in a fashion uh which i had also
which had used back uh in my use
of the principle of stationary potential
energy so if you have watched this video
these terms are not going to look at all
alien to us
except um the only only difference of
interpretation is there
uh there we had written those terms so
let me first write down the term and let
me talk about it later
uh first the contribution from
the force p applied at x equal to l
that is going to give me this thing
written in integration form
plus
this minus b representing the force
p applied in the
negative x direction at x equal to
zero
and then finally of course this familiar
term
okay so what i was saying earlier was
that
the only difference in interpretation of
these terms that i have written here are
falling from here
as compared to what what the
interpretation of these terms were
in the in the previous video when
talking
uh in the context of the use of the
principle of stationary potential energy
is that
these terms were then written uh as the
negative
of the potential energy so or the
potential energy as the negative of the
work done
in these terms but here this is directly
like the work done
by the external externally applied
tractions or various kinds of loadings
all right and we understand that because
we are choosing to use this material
behavior this sigma xx
uh is going to be is going to be like
e times epsilon x x okay
and in the previous page we have already
seen that this epsilon x x
can be written uh in terms of
the the displacement variables so that's
exactly what we are going to proceed
with
okay so what we'll do do here is that
we'll take the left hand side
and we'll try to simplify it okay so so
this equation
this has a left hand side and this is
the right hand side involving three
terms
what we are going to do here now is
consider this left-hand side
all right so this left-hand side
has this volume integral and that can be
written down like this
we have already discussed this and i'm
not going to spend
any more time on on explaining
why this thing is coming out like this
all that i have to do now uh and which
is a little bit different from
our previous use of the principle of
virtual work as applied to the case
where only the lateral loading was
present
is the difference in this expression of
epsilon x x
which in addition to the derivatives of
derivative of w
now also has the derivative of u s
okay so uh what i have now here is if i
just look back
uh here this epsilon x6 is this is this
thing
minus z d squared w d x square plus d u
s d x
i'm going to write that down
final said t square w t x square
plus the us ex
that's my epsilon xx so this epsilon x6
is this
and this first variation of the
epsilon x6 that is going to give me
minus z d square delta w
[Music]
e x square plus t
delta u s e x
so this is d z and d
x but we have to remember that we are
also carrying out an integration
in the y direction but since none of
these variables are dependent on the y
so that integration just gives me
this width b okay so just like before
we are considering a beam which has
a rectangular cross section let me just
point that out here that
my beam has this kind of a rectangular
cross section
where this height here
is h and
this here is b right
and of course the entire length is
capital l uh
okay so that
width b is what we are what we have
written down here
uh we are only dealing with the with the
left hand side
let's see how we can simplify this
first of all we'll just carry out the
multiplication
so this multiplied with this that'll
give
uh that will give us a square
d squared w d x square
d squared delta w d
x square next this multiplied with this
gives us minus z d
squared w dx squared
d delta u s e x
next this multiplied with this gives us
minus z
d u s d x
d square delta w
e x square and finally this multiplied
with this
gives us us
dx e delta u s
dx
all right now
you note that uh
this w this w uh
this us setting the w here this us
w here these this us this us here all of
them
are actually uh
independent of z so i might as well take
those terms
uh out of this integration with respect
to
the z okay so what will be left
so
what is going to happen here is that
if i write this out separately
it will be something like this
you note that this one and this one has
one thing common which is the
coefficient said
so i can i can club these things
together
plus these two things
all right
within bracket and
i have this and finally
i'll have this term which is devoid of
any
contribution from from z up
i would have simplified that but i just
kept it like that okay
now uh we see
that this term here uh
this is this uh this is z cube by three
and uh it's going to give us a non-zero
value
this is of course it's just said
minus h by two to h by two that is also
non-zero
but this however this is an
odd function a submit a an odd function
which is
uh i mean anti-symmetric about
z equal to zero okay so the domain of
integration is from minus h by two h by
two
and what you have here is that uh z
squared by two
after the integration so that uh the
result of this is
zero so this entire term it just
goes away okay this entire term goes
away
and what we'll be left with in the next
step is that if you see
this b times this term
it is just the second moment of area
okay this b
multiplied this entire thing it is just
the second moment of area
uh this is just the height okay
so uh let me let me write that down
uh the next slide
so i'm continuing with my lhs
i have the second moment of area and
then
i have this thing
d squared w d x squared
d squared delta w
x square
dx again i am pointing out that i get
this
second moment of area
by combining this b with this term
okay next
this one is not going to contribute
because
uh this integration here minus h by two
h by 2
that d z that gives me 0 and what i'll
be left with here
from here is this e b h
times this thing okay let me write that
down
so i have a positive sign here
this is d u s d x
times e delta u s
e x d x
all right and you please note that this
bh is nothing but
the total area of the rectangular cross
section
okay so i might write as i'll write that
down here
directly
all right now
uh
you note that this is just the left hand
side but the right hand side
uh if i include that it is going to
start looking
like what we have uh what we had
obtained
earlier so uh so let me just uh
just write that down that
what i mean to say is that if we just
look back at
uh we'll look back at
so what i mean is this
you look at this term so this is
referring to
this page which was or or this step
which was an intermediate step in the
principle
of stationary potential energy
this term here the same as before
that basically involved the
the terms involving the w uh but if you
just look at this one
and this one here and this one here uh
you see that it is equal to zero so
what we have just obtained uh right now
while using the principle of stationary
the principle of virtual work is that in
the left hand side we have obtained this
term
and in the right hand side we have
these terms right
so if we club everything together
if we consider the
if we consider the
lhs
and the rhs
together
and compare
with
with the intermediate step
let's let's call that let's give that
some equation number
so let's say that this is our equation
uh let's say it is
hash or maybe
r star star
from page number 11 make things
everything
make everything clear if you consider
the left hand side and the right hand
side together
from this use of the principle of
virtual work and compare with the
intermediate step from page 11
of
intermediate step from the
the use of the
principle of
of stationary potential energy
we realize that they are exactly the
same thing
so all the subsequent steps that are
going to happen uh as part of our
simplifications
they are exactly going to be the same
and the governing equations and the
boundary conditions that we are going to
end up with they are going to be the
same so finally
we are going to end up
with the
same governing equations
and boundary conditions okay so what i
mean to say is that
uh earlier when we had in this thing
this
this entire thing so we are again going
to
just identically obtain the exact same
thing
all right so uh there is no point
in actually going through those things
in a repeated fashion
uh but what i again would like to very
much emphasize is that
uh whether it is the use of the
principle of stationary potential energy
or the or the principle
of virtual work what is happening is
that
the uh the stretching variable
uh the the governing equation involving
the stretching variable
and the governing equation involving the
the transverse deflection variable
they are coming out in a completely
decoupled fashion
okay they're coming out completely
separately so
what is happening is that in the
equation so if you look back
uh in the equation for the us
there is no presence of the w and in the
equation for the w there is no presence
of the u.s so these two
are completely separate so as if the
physics
of the stretching and the physics of the
transverse deflection
represented by this w they are occurring
as if
independently from each other okay and
this where is the problem
associated with buckling okay so
this is something which we need to
address
and correct and which will do in our
next video
so on that note
on that note i will end this video on
the use of the principle of virtual work
uh thank you very much